Where is 30 on the number line?
So on the number
line right over here,
we see that as we go from
0, the first slash isn't 1.
It's 3.
So every slash here is
going to go up by 3.
So let's see if we can
figure out where 30 is.
So this is already marked as 3.
Now this is going to be 3 more.
It's 6, 9, 12, 15,
18, 21, 24, 27, 30.
Another way you could
have thought about it
is if each of these marks
are 3, to get to 30,
we have to go to
10 of these marks.
So you go 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Let's do a few more.
Where is 24 on the number line?
Well, once again, each of
these marks is again 3.
So it's going to be 3, 6,
9, 12, 15, 18, 21, and 24.
Let's do one more.
So now each mark is 4.
So we're going to
go 4, 8, 12, 16, 20.
Another way you
could think about it
is if we're going up by 4,
you have to go up 5 times
to get up to 20.
So this is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Either way, this should
be the right answer.